Hi.
My name is Ken Shotts.
>> And I'm Neil Malhotra.
And we would like to introduce you to
the course on Values-Based Leadership.
>> This course is about how
to lead with our values and
implement them in our organizations.
Gaining a better understanding of our own
value systems can make us more effective
managers and help us be the kinds
of leaders people want to follow.
Clarifying our value systems will also
help us make better decisions for
the benefit of key stakeholders,
such as shareholders, employees,
costumers, and society at large.
>> This course will address several key
questions in values based leadership.
Should we make decisions
based on our gut intuitions?
How can we design organizations
to prevent ethical lapses?
What is the role of companies in society?
How can we manage trade-offs and
weigh the consequences of our actions?
And how can we engage in
perspective-taking to build more inclusive
and fair organizations?
>> These questions are complicated,
and they don't have easy answers.
The goal of this course,
is to engage with these stony issues, so
that we can better lead with our values.
By the end of this course, you will
clarify your own values, gain a better
understanding of the diversity of
ethical perspectives in business, and
learn how to lead and design organizations
to implement your personal values.